hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Katie
do what we're gonna be checking out a
channel cinemasins I said before the one
of my top five favorite channels and I
haven't been watching their videos as
much as I wanted to lately so I wanted
to catch up and I saw that this came out
forever ago and I'm surprised I never
saw it everything wrong with inception
in four minutes or less most of their
videos are like 10 to 20 minutes so they
really couldn't find that much wrong
with inception apparently good
I love inception yeah so I thought it'd
be cool if we like kind of do this and
there's spoilers in it so if you haven't
seen inception or spoilers and I thought
like we could kind of do like a little
spoiler review afterwards as well based
off what they're talking about Wow Wow
is that your thing is that is that the
character you're creating for yourself
on this channel well I was going to the
awkwardly Erwin doesn't seem like you
like it
no that's the music they're like oh no I
got that oh that wasn't the problem
oh and she's never seen this before no I
don't know that
how come Saito can have bodyguard
projections in limbo why doesn't anyone
else in the film of bodyguard
projections when they go to limbo
I'll trust the projection of his
mistress dead wife to service the anchor
for his room ah this guy's their
architect it isn't over the kick is the
architect gets every detail of Saito's
apartment correct down to the pillow gun
and the carpet stains but gets the
material at the carpet wrong this Asian
kid is so important to the story he
doesn't get a name and then disappears
for the rest of the fifth there's
surprisingly little wind and noise when
standing underneath the helicopter and
two things to say about this maze one it
doesn't look very hard to it's actually
impossible look II mean think okay what
invisible thing is just stepping over
which he pulls the mirrors God knows
he's going into Cobell Energy's backyard
and that they wanted to death but he has
no escape plan in mind except to run but
ykm Abbasid stands out with a black guy
at Martha's Vineyard oh there's someone
going that definitely means the guy
we're tracing like this way these
founding owners are terrible shots well
this is beyond convenient honestly why
would a guy this omniscient even need
the services of Kaabah company hey look
it's the scientist from Avatar playing
exactly the stuff just starting to fall
over but earlier cobster fell all the
way into the water before he fell to
kick the flight attendant pulls his
curtain then turns to get the briefcase
then turns they hand it to Arthur which
she's only able to do because the
curtain is now opening it this guy is
standing right here firing into an open
rear window he's not hitting anything at
all all this screaming you would think
he would have at least one witness to
support the claim that he didn't kill
his wife he had herself declared sane by
three different signed because that's
not suspicious at all so I ran but why
didn't you just wait for forensic
science to prove that your wife jump
from another building all together and
you know your fingerprints aren't
anywhere in the ransacked hotel room if
you can just dream up bigger guns why
the [ __ ] they leave this warehouse in
the tank then go into the water that's a
kick band tumbling over and over on its
side and not a kick
got it right the changes directions
between camera angles why do the rules
of gravity extend the second level dream
but not the third level snow much should
they've all gone flying off the mountain
into the air
Fisher partners up a Saito his company's
biggest and only true rival in worldwide
energy domination and movie doesn't
recognize paradox thing is cool but it
only happens because the bad guys in the
spooky cannot aim
or grids a couple minutes so you're
saying in a couple of minutes Arthur has
an air fight with this agent Smith dude
retreats the charges arranges these
suits in a stack obtains a bunch of wire
bundles up these idiots roofs them down
the hall puts them in the elevator all
in a couple of minutes I'm pretty sure
that's not as easy as she makes it sound
the malls gonna be demolition now is
cops projection and not a real person
so why did she go to limbo after cobb
shoots her and how she able to kidnap
Fisher before Cobb even gets to limbo so
can they get out of the ocean completely
drive just moments later why is he
making a ransom deal with his own
projection it's basically just talking
to himself here it could be rescuing
Fisher's considering the kick Arthur's
setting up in the hotel dream level
above and the fact that everyone gets
out of limbo by suicide is there even a
reason for this explosion or disease
just like the Bluebell Ariana forces two
people to die all the falling guns from
a skyscraper which she could have shot
the both in the head with the gun she
used to shoot map table is basically the
same age but silo super old even though
they both entered limbo about the same
time English citizens don't get
passports stamped upon returning to the
country awesome
happily ever after hey did the Cobell
Engineering's because still want a
murderer okay let's talk about Dodos
why's cops stowed in just a normal table
but everyone else's totem is weighted or
hollowed out or otherwise jacked up
Arthur won't let Ariana touch his way to
die because only he knows what number
it's supposed to land on but then
everyone knows a top falls there's
nothing unique about the behavior of
cops totem also why does it totally show
up in the dream in the first place
does the dreamer take it with them
subconscious n' are they able to control
it and if they are I can't they control
all kinds of other put their minds
watering dreams why do they even have to
be behind the wheel of the car to make a
drop site Oh tuchis cops totem which is
a no no that was at limbo so it's that
bad why do the totems even have to be
there inside the dreams like why can't
the method for determining your
realities be the simple that the other
totem in your pocket just don't take the
totem into the dream do I'm coding in my
pocket right now hmm no still dreaming
dreaming or not you're just gonna let
that top spin and make it wobble a bit
and tease us with a cut to black you
brilliant mother
I didn't realize how much continuity
issues that movie had I disagree with
some of their issues oh no of course
some other issues for sure I don't ever
fully agree I just think they had the
time sequencing wrong the further you go
down dreaming within the dream within
the dream time moves so like if we were
in four levels down dreaming okay one
minute would just be like one minute to
us but someone in the next level it
would be an hour someone in the level
after that it would be a day so the fact
that they're like oh we only have like
ten minutes
Jason gordon-levitt does all of this
stuff it's because it's like ten hours
longer it's like ten hours he has to do
that stuff in there ten minutes hmm whoa
no no did you understand interstellar I
did understand interstellar that's so
did I but I don't think any of the
degree you did like the time to really
point out that some things are just a
little bit like too convenient yeah like
come on like when they're talking about
how the architect doesn't know the kick
and then the RA tickets everything right
but the material of the carpet that's
sure like things like that will bother
me and I'm glad we have people like this
too pointed out oh good but I do feel
like the beginning of the movie when
he's running through the market is
within one of his dreams that's why
there are things that don't make sense
like the very incredibly narrowed not
hallway but like alley that he tries to
go through that gets so narrow he could
barely fit through that's exactly like a
dream that's why some of those things in
that sequence didn't quite make sense
because he was within one of his dream
lands I'm okay with small contiune
continuity issues there because I think
that's part of the puzzle of the movie
is they're supposed to continue to be
unsure of where your realities are
realities are
are we in a reality right now what
you're doing is amazing right now
thank you my mind would not have
ventured to where your mind has gone
with understanding inception and its
continuity issue I think Nolan in
himself has kind of continuity issues
with a lot of his films he's always
doing montages all his handhelds but he
worked on this for years
yeah years he worked on this movie so
you would think that like he's really
ironed out sort of the philosophy that
it was behind each level the reason why
the guy in one level they get pushed
over in the chair and it doesn't and it
wakes him up right away and the next
time he gets pushed over in the chair
but into the tub is because every layer
they go down they have to up the kick Oh
first they have the chair being pushed
over next they have the chair being
pushed into the tub next they have the
van being pushed into the water so we're
seeing the continuity each time with
them having impact right where they up
the stakes each time depending on how
far and then she throws herself and the
other two off the really tall building
down into the why can't why couldn't she
shoot them though because it's the
continuity of the dream sequences all
taking place I think it's because um
their impact has to wake them up if you
actually die if you actually get killed
and they made this point in the movie if
you actually get killed you're dead but
the second your body begins to hit the
water is still going to be like three
days before your body actually hits the
water to the extent that you would die
so you're gonna wake up in your next
level but hey I know brilliant do you
ever need anything explained just let me
know pretty good pretty good
well you followed the script that I
wrote really well good job on the
monologues you know I spent like three
days writing them and knew the best
actress I could have hired to say all
the things that you just said because
you're welcome because I get all the
credit I get passionate about my words
of course not my observations well thank
you for hiring me mm-hmm I didn't
understand half the stuff I just said
but if you well it makes sense but you
had conviction at the end of the day you
you at least acted like you understood
which made me go wow this is actually
pretty believable
we've deviated it's so far but look guys
I know some of you you're gonna go
Ryan's an idiot and yeah I am there
should have been more to that sentence
doesn't have to be you just all they're
gonna be like that girl's hot and cute
and and smart and but this guy is just
dump this guy he doesn't even have a
thought he's just dumb and hairy so dumb
and hairy
excuse me a lot I have nothing to say
that was perfect
anyway guys do the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where you
get brains and looks in one video by
Katie du Bois
sometimes she's on here and her channel
the link is right here if you have a
computer that allows you to see
annotations it's right there and
subscribe button up here I'm a youtuber
so I'm supposed to be saying these
things cool hey you know you can do to
you follow me on Instagram and Twitter
and and [ __ ] uh was it a chat face
back face back face book face back face
back watch Ryan Clark can I get a shout
out that Judah MacDonald's got five
fired chicken ha there's this video of
this guy who lost his [ __ ] at McDonald's
oh my got fired so he said that guy
McCall's got fired chicken mm-hmm not
cuz it's like fried chicken but fired
but it's fire chicken his name's also
Ryan it makes sense why he has such
great humor because the Ryan's know what
they're doing when we're twins and if
we're twins that means we both have
regular sized penis I have a twin really
hey - do you have regular the equally
sized penises No
is he is he a guy or girl it's a girl
twin girls does she look like you
no she doesn't she's blonde and like
blue-eyed we look totally different for
this same we're twins can we see if a
river uh there's a picture on my
facebook of us together then let's see
with oh she got married yeah yeah who
the [ __ ] gonna care about seeing
picture me cuz I love my sister I was
gonna send Ryan Clark a photo so he
could like you know touch himself to her
or something now he's not going to do
that because she's married yeah that's
weird it's awkward when girls married to
you
Sonic from Mimas agra for a lot of other
guys I'm just gonna leave her alone yeah
that seemed safe since it yes safe is
the word